[Music]
for the first time in his 20-year term
president erdogan faces a second round
in turkey's presidential election
President recep Tai erdogan has 49.41
his main rival Kamal kalistarolo has
nearly 45
with the results down to the wire the
Electoral campaigns are heating up is
foreign
as voters grapple with inflation at 44
an ongoing currency crisis will the
economy be the election's deciding
factor
[Music]
I think the expectation going into this
election was that this election would
reflect people's attitudes toward the
economy and those attitudes have been
overwhelmingly negative I mean a vast
majority of Turks you know think that
the economy is not heading in the right
direction the economy is believed to be
running on borrowed time at this point
erdogan has been kicking the can down
the road for the past year or so
um through his mix of Highly unorthodox
policies and by spending foreign
reserves to keep the exchange rate in
check
foreign
at this point the oppositions most
likely path to Victory assuming there is
a path
is
to Focus exclusively in on on the
economy erdogan's success in this
election was to have deflected attention
away from the state of the economy that
the election came down to Identity and
that it came down to a big projects it
came down to vision and it came down to
National Security the unveiled one Mega
project after another you know a
turkey's newest and biggest warship
turkey's first ever electric car
turkey's first nuclear plant all of this
in the space of a month practically and
he also accused the opposition of siding
with you know Kurdish separatists these
messages actually resonated with a large
share of the populist
the remarkable thing about erdogan's
electorate is that they understand you
know to a large extent that erdogan and
his policies might be to blame for
turkey's current uh economic woes and
especially for inflation
but
um they trust him to be able to repair
things so whether he's able to do so
whether he's willing to do so I think is
another question because
the set of Economic and monetary
policies in place right now is a recipe
for more inflation
um and probably uh yet another currency
crisis and that's going obviously to
lead to
deterioration of living standards and
sort of a never-ending cost of living
crisis needs to earn the support and the
trust of the five percent of the
electorate who voted for sinan Owen who
was the third candidate in this election
what he has to do is to sort of bring
the debate back to the economy
and then and only then does he have a
shot at our victory in the runoff
[Music]